declaring an international public health
emergency is rare but with the corona
virus spreading globally the World
Health Organization says it warrants a
coordinated international response I'm
declaring a public health emergency of
international concern over the global
outbreak of novel : of a corona virus
the main reason for this declaration is
not because of what is happening in
China but because of what is happening
in other countries our greatest concern
is the potential for the virus to spread
to countries with weaker health systems
and which are ill prepared to deal with
it countries like India one of the
latest to report cases of the
respiratory disease until now individual
nations have made their own decision in
response to the outbreak in Italy more
than six thousand tourists were under
lockdown aboard a cruise ship near Rome
after two Chinese passengers displayed
flu-like symptoms
the couple were put into isolation until
their test results came back negative
for coronavirus meanwhile evacuations of
foreign nationals from Wuhan continue
turkey sent a military cargo plane to
bring back 35 Turkish and 10 Azerbaijani
citizens and their families all
including the crew will now be put under
quarantine for 14 days the EU is
bringing back another 350 Europeans on a
flight into Portugal and 150 British
nationals will touch down in the UK on
Friday this is a number of commercial
airlines suspended flights to China a
decision the w-h-o is now asking them to
revise why did you take this decision
why what is the science supporting this
decision could you reconsider this
decision and we suggested to w-h-o that
w-h-o should inform the world about
transparency concerning these measures
which should not consist
shoot an example to follow but a
decision to reconsider for China the
w-h-o only had praise for their efforts
to contain the virus but it is still
spreading fast the message what will
protect us is not fear and a version but
solidarity and cooperation charlie
angela al jazeera let's go live now to
scott Heidler he is in Beijing Scott
many countries are trying to get their
citizens out of who buy but China is
looking to bring its expanse back yes
it's very interesting move by China what
they're going to do is they're going to
dispatch charter aircraft they haven't
said exactly where to bring those
residents those citizens of China who
are residents of these affected areas
back into China now it said it didn't
really go into too much detail just said
because the difficulties they're facing
so most likely that is because there has
been definitely cancellation of all
flights into where they're from Wuhan
City or oh babe who Bay province in
general but also because other airlines
are canceling their flights into China
generally so it's become much more
difficult for Chinese citizens who are
abroad to come back home it'll be
interesting to see where these charter
aircraft actually land who Han Airport
is obviously open to charter aircraft
only overs we're seeing those
evacuations from the growing list of
nations who are taking their citizens
out of Wuhan so be interesting to see
what happens with these Chinese citizens
are they going to fly them straight back
into Wuhan who are from there or is it
gonna land in in a different city and
then they'll take them down by special
bus we're not sure yet and obviously
they'll have to make some decisions
about where they keep them and if they
do actually go into the affected area so
it's an interesting move by China know
one thing that they announced over the
last couple of days is they're also
going to dispatch charter aircraft into
Wuhan on the who Bay Province area
affected area to bring people Chinese
citizens who aren't from there who are
tourists stuck in there obviously
they're gonna test them then they'll
bring them out and so they have the
opportunity to go back to their homes in
other places in China so the Chinese
government trying to work for their
citizens as well as we're seeing this
airlift out of Wuhan for foreign
citizens and Scott the numbers of
inflictions continues to
what's the latest in terms of
containment efforts right now I couldn't
really hear too well there Kim the
situation right now with the latest
numbers obviously we're seeing these
numbers increase every day those who
have been affected infected by this
virus and that the death numbers what
we're seeing you know as a response from
the Chinese government they are you know
they're two hospitals they're being
built right now in Wuhan to deal with
the growing number of patients down
there one is supposed to open in just a
few days on Monday they're saying that's
when it's going to open up now it's very
difficult to know you know how quickly
they're going to be able to start to
accept patients they say that this first
hospital is going to have about a
thousand beds a few days later maybe at
the end of next week another a second
hospital purpose-built hospital around
the Wuhan area to take in more patients
there's also a hospital a grounds for a
hospital just outside Beijing here that
was used back 17 years ago 2003 during
the SARS crisis that is being rebuilt if
you will so they can have more beds for
specifically the corona virus infected
so that should be coming in in the next
couple of weeks they expect so right now
that's the Chinese government moved to
deal with the current situation we know
that there is a shortage of medical
supplies down in Wuhan and that's
something the government is trying to
deal with other supplies we've been
speaking to people in Wuhan other
supplies food and water that's okay
right now though the focus is on those
medical supplies think of that that's
got hider they're live from Beijing